met them because I was in my son's dad
for nine years and he's ended up with
the one that kind of he cheated and then
he cheated and she then was like the
last cheat
if that makes sense so that he cheated
on each person with each person and then
he's ended up with the one that would
and maybe she accepted it that's weird
um so what what are you I was that so
guys what do you what do you think I
think it depends on the guy and where
their headspace is at because I mean I
know that I'm an anomaly so I can't
really talk for all guys but I know that
when we met I kind of already made that
conscious choice and I remember having
that conversation with my mum when I was
16 and being like yeah I think if I
start with this one that's gonna be it
but I can understand why most guys until
later in life won't really get to that
stage so I think is where they're at in
their headspace I don't think it's about
the time
um so you think it's it sounds like you
said more at the right time no no it's
well where they are yeah where they are
so the girl that's there at the right
time yeah okay would you guys agree with
that anyone disagree with that no I
don't disagree with that I agree with
that wherever like and the most men
won't even commit into a situation if
they ain't where they want to be in
their head yeah you know I mean if you
if I meet somebody because I can meet
somebody anywhere and at any time but
I've always got a master plan Pinky and
the Brain plan in my head that I've had
from since I was young that where I'm
going to achieve in life so if somebody
comes in and shows attributes that
they're gonna add to that Journey
they're more likely and more likely to
like keep that person around because
they're not taken away from where I'm
trying to go they're adding to it versus
if it's somebody who's got their own
life going on and they don't really want
to you know involve themselves in your
life so much it will it's kind of an
easy choice to me be like all right I'll
hook up with you but I don't see this
going Beyond where it is it feels more
like man is whichever one comes first if
the right one comes first they'll start
for the right one if the right one
doesn't come first they'll settle at the
right time but don't you think that's
because they can if it goes adapted or
adaptable to their lifestyle and they
get on with the program
then they can they can figure into what
they want from their life do you think
do you think that I'm just saying true
or untrue can the right girl make a guy
settle down when he's not ready country
yeah
respectfully I'm asking the man like
quite like that's true you should have
to be like seriously
like Kate Middleton like
serious okay so you guys all think
that's true absolutely may I ask a
question what is it that makes a man not
be wanting to settle if she's the right
one uh that makes us don't want to sell
they do if she's the right one why would
you pass on the right one the girl that
is actually has nothing wrong she likes
you like her everything so I mean I
don't know why would you say no I don't
know maybe some men don't want to give
up that lifestyle that they live in all
or she I don't know like oh they're just
what's the lifestyle saying that is
better than finding the woman
is addicted to the girl's attention or
getting girls or doing things with girls
and they they don't want to settle down
I don't know sometimes just like the
streets yeah so yes I'm saying some guys
just love their love they're stuck in
the streets and they don't know how to
get away so so like I'm just saying like
obviously some
the situations we need to not also take
accountability because the right woman
will sometimes come across the right the
man and because he's not in the right
place in his mind because he likes the
streets too much because he doesn't want
to make sure that's the other woman but
but that's not the point is not that
because if she picked him and he has now
a position of choice he's not making the
right choice so we can't continue
who are you to say it's the wrong
decision maybe it's the right to sit
like sometimes it's the best thing that
ever happened to him sometimes it wasn't
okay and then so I said so this this was
what I said I said whichever comes first
so when you settle at the right time
that you feel like it's the right time
but you've missed out on the right one
it's likely to be the case where you're
gonna actually pick somebody that's
probably not gonna be the best for you
so I would just say instead of you
always trying to think about the right
time if the right person comes along
that's the first priority that's it
that's it you shouldn't pass on the
right side I think that's a female Point
that's definitely the right person
because if we if we find the right guy
we'll drop everything but like men just
aren't built like us but they all said
if there's an extremely exceptional
woman they'll do it yeah and so it's
just you ain't that girl
if this is the thing and that is also
one of the the issues that I have
because we like to point out problems
but then when the solution comes into
the table everybody rejects it how is it
that we can sit here and complain about
men or the girls this girls make my
decisions Men by make my decisions and
we say no yeah if I'm not in the right
space I'll let the right one go and then
you're happy to say something like that
but when you pick that like okay okay
women pick men that clearly aren't in
the space of their lives to settle down
like I'm sorry I'm 26. if I if I dated
26 year old he's probably not ready
women try to date their age and then
they're confused why he's not ready to
settle down this is why I wanted
yeah yeah I mean and there's like and
also I mean some some guys are right but
it's usually pretty obvious which ones
are and which ones are and if you ask
they'll usually tell you but we don't
listen okay so then let me ask you
another question and so since we always
keep talking about youth right
um I don't think youth in a woman means
it's the right time for for you to be
with her which means all these men that
high value in their 30 going for younger
women really they might be making
mistakes you don't get to pick it the
men get to pick what they want that's
what men find is valuable is that me
going into a shop and like oh I want to
buy this t-shirt no you can't buy this
t-shirt you go buy this t-shirt okay
because it's like okay if a man if a man
wants four kids why on Earth would he
pick a 30 year old okay that makes no
sense yeah I'm 35 and there's no way I
would date somebody who wants to have
multiple children I am not ready to walk
around with a big old belly and have a
baby on my baby yeah and you probably
and you would be in geriatric pregnancy
I mean I think my eggs are good but I
mean you think yeah it'll be risky yeah
it's still a risk yes I'm not willing
why would a man I'm explaining the
simple fact that you cannot be
complaining about women saying that
women doing this in women doing that
when you're picking them at the wrong
time that's what I'm saying
exactly so then so then while we're
talking about age
there's less trauma less baggage and
they look better okay the same way that
that women prefer the richest the top
four percent and actually a lot of the
time but the difference the difference
is what men want is attainable what
women want isn't it
that's attainable in the way that we're
talking about what isn't crazy it's
usually not crazy under 30 under 30
roughly maybe you know most guys will
even be generous they'll give you like
33 34 whatever about 35. the bags are
good I'm sorry okay I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry so again
but it's not crazy okay now I'll tell
you why it's also crazy because this is
again another problem we've met man why
are you picking just based on the fact
that woman is under 30.
and that's
so so it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what you want or what you think
your eggs are gone
before you explain something let me cut
you off forever okay so I take back the
fact that I like you I don't like in the
more continue my answer was was um so I
always uh have you seen rum diaries with
Johnny Depp
I like that the kind of lifestyle of
like being a well-traveled dude who's
experiencing so it depends on the guy
some guys are very conservative and they
want to settle down straight after
University I always I always wanted to I
always wanted to experience the world
and to come back and have experiences of
value that would allow me to add an
Engaged relationship in a certain way
which is why I'm a little bit more
tolerant than the conservative guys and
some of these standards so I'll take the
parents of the guy because I'm not
really driven by oh I'm gonna meet
someone going to connect so much I'm
going to drop everything
um it has to be a point where I've
decided in my mind that like all right
I've seen enough this is getting long
let me start like preparing to chill out
you know as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible